[Music]
on this thursday night canada's latest
contribution to ukraine
the troops being deployed not for combat
but to help refugees we will do whatever
is needed plus russia admits its
flagship of the black sea fleet has sunk
i was also dealing with a
feeling of did that just really happen
the trauma of rcmp officers we've all
struggled who stopped the nova scotia
mass murderer
big dig it was a snowball the punishing
storm pummeling the prairies and hashtag
hostile takeover i think it's hit a
boiling point for him why does
billionaire elon musk want to buy
twitter
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
up to 150 members of the canadian armed
forces are preparing for deployment
tonight as ottawa ramps up efforts to
help ukrainians who are fleeing russia's
war in their country the un's refugee
agency estimates more than 4.7 million
people have now left their homes in
ukraine the majority over 2.6 million
have crossed the border into poland
since late february that's where the
small contingent of canadian troops is
heading a part of a humanitarian mission
ottawa has promised to take in an
unlimited number of ukrainians the
country has now endured 50 days of
russian bombardment what the country's
president says he needs immediately is
more heavy weapons from the west to
prevent what he calls a coming bloodbath
david akin has our top story on canada's
latest contribution
canadian forces members are headed to
eastern europe on a humanitarian mission
not a combat mission which means that
those being deployed include medical
personnel chaplains and those trained in
civilian military operations we will do
whatever is needed to ensure
that we are supporting ukraine and also
that we are making our respective
contributions on the ground to the nato
alliance and this mission in poland is
part of that commitment
there are three different components to
the mission first canadian troops will
be stationed at reception centers on the
polish border which are the entry points
for the millions of ukrainians that have
fled their country into poland these
canadians will assist with processing
and provide immediate needs and many of
these canadians speak ukrainian we send
anyone to these different operations in
different locations around the world we
try to ensure that they have the
linguistic capability such that we can
integrate better with the folks we're
trying to help
second some canadians will be part of a
polish-led humanitarian assistance force
providing medical care and other aid
finally canadian military personnel will
help canadian civil servants who are
trying to process applications from
ukrainians who want to come to canada
the government says this will help
thousands more ukrainians come to canada
more quickly
but what the ukrainian government wants
is weapons canada did set aside 500
million dollars in last week's budget to
buy guns and ammunition for ukraine
canada's defense minister says she is
consulting closely with her ukrainian
counterpart to spend that money quickly
minister resnikoff is in touch with me
almost daily in terms of what is needed
for ukraine and that's what i'm working
to fulfill in terms of the list now
canada will deploy a hundred canadian
forces personnel at first more to follow
their departure is in the quote
immediate term we can't tell you the
exact time the flights will leave that's
in order to protect the operational
security of the mission but we can tell
you that the troops will be deployed for
at least two months and if circumstances
warrant their mission could be extended
donna all right david aiken thanks
russia now admits its naval flagship of
the black sea fleet has sunk ukraine
says it was sunk by a missile strike
russia denies that western officials
have not been able to verify the cause
but whatever it is as mike armstrong
reports the ship's loss is a big blow to
russia
two months have brought a lot of change
this is video of russia's flagship
vessel in its black sea fleet the moskva
when the russian military released the
video back in february it was a show of
force now it appears to have been a sign
of overconfidence
according to this ukrainian military
spokesman its forces hit the ship with a
missile it started a fire and the ship
started sinking the russian military has
a different story it isn't acknowledging
any attack saying simply there was a
fire and the ship had to be evacuated
when ammunition started exploding it's a
big blow to russia washington hasn't
confirmed either story but the u.s
national security adviser says it looks
bad on russia whether it was an attack
or an accident what he calls
incompetence and neither is a
particularly good
outcome for them
russian officials are pushing their own
supposed success stories this spokesman
claiming the last 24 hours their
aircraft hit seven military facilities
in eastern ukraine
that region is very much now the focus
for russian troops in particular the
donbass region the port city of mariupol
appears to be close to falling under
russian control if it hasn't already the
ukrainian foreign minister says the news
coming out of the besieged city is hard
to hear
to unblock marijuana and to save them
literally to save them
we need
more weapons
[Applause]
now canada is one of the countries
helping with those weapons but the
deputy prime minister said thursday
there's also a focus on war crimes
rape is being used as a weapon in this
war we are not going to forget
and we will work with ukraine
and with our democratic allies around
the world to bring the perpetrators to
justice
now on the western side of ukraine
tensions appear to be tightening the
netherlands thursday showed off four
f-35s it's now deployed in bulgaria to
reinforce nato's eastern flank with
russia our coalition operations send a
strong signal to the russian aggressor
that chose to invade a sovereign
european nation
moscow meantime is pushing back it says
it's watching the buildup on its borders
and says its defense ministry is working
on plans in response
mike armstrong global news
in this country through the worst of the
pandemic federal support programs were a
lifeline for millions of canadians but
many small businesses racked up big
debts and were hoping for more help in
the last federal budget
now with covet cases on the rise and
shortages of labor some businesses have
had to shut their doors again abigail
beamen on how some of them are
struggling to stay afloat
[Music]
at ottawa's union local 613 the sixth
wave hits hard edges are devastating
it's pretty brutal
most of ivan gedz's staff got kovid 19
and the restaurant lost tens of
thousands of dollars in a short-term
closure customer numbers aren't back to
normal and fixed costs like rent don't
change there's certainly
drastic
stressors on our bottom line with
federal covid supports ending geds
didn't see anything in the new budget
that would directly help even as the
prime minister and deputy prime minister
do the rounds promoting the budget's aid
for small business there is still
specific support
in place for the hardest hit industries
until may 7th so there's still some
runway there the average small business
has taken on 160 000 in debt and even as
they slowly crawl out of of covid and
start to win back some of their
customers
they haven't had a regular month of
sales in two years
the canadian federation of independent
business says only forty percent of
small businesses see pre-pandemic
revenue levels they were calling for
more loan forgiveness and help and don't
give this budget high marks a c or a d
there were a few good things for small
businesses but overall it was a big
missed opportunity the biggest good
thing a shift in the tax rate right now
businesses pay a lower nine percent rate
on the first half a million of taxable
income so long as taxable capital is
under 15 million dollars after that they
hit the regular 15 rate budget 2022
would let them keep paying 9
until they hit 50 million in taxable
capital instead and while the finance
minister says it's important to
recognize businesses hard work across
the country she also stresses times have
changed that was
emergency spending for a specific
emergency period and that that period is
over
businesses still dealing with long-term
impacts may feel differently
abigail beeman global news ottawa
now to nova scotia there was some
powerful testimony today at the public
inquiry into the mass shooting in april
2020. the rcmp has been widely
criticized for how it responded to the
gunman who is disguised as a police
officer and killed 22 people but as ross
lord reports the rcmp members testifying
today played a pivotal role in
preventing even more deaths
during the 13-hour murder rampage rcmp
officers failed to contain the gunman
struggling with computer technology and
communication 22 people died but there
might have been even more carnage if not
for two maudies who ended the massacre
killing the gunman at this gas station
by coincidence the killer denturist
gabriel wartman pulled in for fuel at
the same time as constables ben mcleod
and craig hubley he discarded his bogus
rcmp car and changed out of his police
uniform he was sweaty
he was breathing hard and he had his
mouth open
he looked like a prize fighter sitting
down between rounds like that kind of
exhaustion the officers told the public
inquiry when the gunman reached for a
handgun they opened fire pump six
enfield
suspect is down in his vehicle multiple
shots away there's another key detail
the rcmp has never mentioned until now
as i started to shoot
simultaneously the perpetrator brought
that pistol up to the right side of his
temple the gunman shot himself with the
smith and wesson pistol he stole from
one of his victims rcmp constable heidi
stevenson nova scotia's chief medical
examiner testified it's likely the
lethal shots came from hubley and mcleod
i was also dealing with a
feeling of did that just really happen
it was it was such a shock we've all
struggled we
we saw a lot that night
and every one of us
every one of us just wanted to find them
their decisive actions don't erase
questions about the rcmp's overall
response and their failure to initiate
an emergency alert for the general
public that might have prevented some of
the 22 murders the vast majority of nova
scotians
were oblivious to the seriousness of the
threat
and to the proximity of this of the
threat the inquiry will not sit next
week the second anniversary of the
massacre an intro report is due in may
with a final report planned for november
ross lord global news
in new york city the man who federal
prosecutors say carried out a violent
well-planned attack on the subway has
been ordered to be held without bail
prosecutors say 62-year-old frank james
is a flight risk and an ongoing danger
to the community james was arrested
wednesday after a 30-hour manhunt he
faces a federal terrorism charged
accused of setting off smoke bombs and
firing dozens of shots inside a crowded
subway train prosecutors say at least 30
people were injured if convicted james
could spend life in prison
the big cleanup after hunkering down
next how the prairies just can't escape
winter
[Music]
people in parts of southern saskatchewan
and manitoba are surveying huge snow
drifts wondering how long it will take
to dig out the extreme weather is
expected to taper off tomorrow and
winnipeg was spared the very worst of it
heather urix west is there for us again
tonight heather
donna it has been two days of wind and
snow here in the city with the wind
chill now approaching minus 20. but
winnipeggers are counting themselves
lucky having escaped the massive amount
of snow now blanketing several other
communities in southern manitoba and
saskatchewan
they knew the storm was coming but for
the people of estevan saskatchewan this
much snow was still a bit of a shock it
was a snowball
24 hours and we got 10 12 foot snow
banks cars were buried
we got jacked up trucks horrible drive
trucks stuck all over town city
officials are calling it the worst storm
this community has ever seen though they
definitely were not alone northwest of
winnipeg the on and on manitoba area saw
almost 90 centimeters fall in a single
day
i think the biggest thing was oh wow my
car is buried in the snow
and we somehow have to get to the farm
because we're farmers and so we do have
to feed the cows
in winnipeg most students remained off
school thursday enjoying the first snow
days for all metro school divisions in
25 years
people can build a snowman
the city of winnipeg saw about 30
centimeters of snow on wednesday less
than some forecasters had expected but
more than enough to put a wrench in
easter plans i got a daughter supposed
to plays in the band supposed to be
going to regina in the weekend but i'm
guessing that's probably not happening
the good news is it is mid-april and
sooner or later winter will come to an
end it's the last blast of the year and
after this we get summer it has been a
long winter and it's not over yet there
is still more snow in the forecast for
friday but the worst of this storm
system at least has come to an end donna
all right heather yurix west in winnipeg
thanks with me now is global news
meteorologist anthony farnell anthony
what's it looking like for the long
weekend
donna i'm here in sunny and mild toronto
a much different story in the prairies
incredible amounts of snow blowing snow
and wind chills that are still in the
teens below freezing as a meteorologist
you look at a weather map like this and
you don't imagine it to be the middle of
april but that's just what we have let's
start with those warnings through
southern manitoba and now into
northwestern ontario where an additional
potentially 20 to 30 centimeters could
fall but this is up over a much less
less populated area another three to
eight centimeters for hard hit areas
like winnipeg so the low continues even
into your good friday as it moves
through ontario into parts of northern
quebec as well it is all-encompassing
check out the satellite imagery from
saskatchewan all the way to halifax over
3 000 kilometers across it also extends
down to the gulf coast where severe
weather's been a problem and all of this
is slow to move so as we head into
friday and saturday the low starts to
weaken that's good news
it is going to remain cold that can be
good news as well you don't want all of
this to melt in the prairies all at once
the bad news is that by easter sunday
potentially we could see more snow as
another system moves through it will
eventually warm up it might not be until
the end of next week donna back to you
all right anthony farnell thanks
ahead a one-way ticket to rwanda boris
johnson's plan for asylum seekers in the
uk
you're watching global national
[Music]
britain's prime minister has a new plan
for asylum seekers arriving on small
boats from france boris johnson wants to
send them to rwanda one of the poorest
countries in the world his government is
paying rwanda nearly 200 million dollars
to take in people the uk turns away
calling it a bold step to break the
business model of people smugglers as
crystal commansing reports critics have
jumped on it as a chilling cruel and
nasty idea
the uk signing over the fate of asylum
seekers
rwanda will receive process and resettle
all those deemed by the uk as illegal
migrants in exchange for an initial
investment of 120 million pounds this is
part of the united kingdom's new plan
for immigration to control our borders
protect our communities stop dangerous
illegal migration
revamping immigration has been on the
tory to-do list for years and prime
minister boris johnson needs a victory
he's embroiled in a coveted party
scandal as the first pm to have been
found breaking the law while in office
if they come across the channel
illegally in these in these vessels then
they uh risk ending up not in the uk uh
but in rwanda and
that is something that i believe will
over time prove a very considerable
deterrent
on the day johnson unveiled his
government's new plan more people
including small children were plucked
from the world's busiest shipping
channel it's a dangerous journey many
people have died trying to make it
across from europe but that risk hasn't
stopped crossings from rising from a few
hundred migrants in 2018 to nearly 29
000 last year with tens of millions of
people around the world displaced by
violence war induced poverty and
persecution
immigration is a hot button issue
australia most notably moved to offshore
processing sites but has since scaled
back efforts with reports of human
rights violations
the opposition labor leader says britain
deserves better it's a desperate
announcement unworkable extortionate
refugee advocates say if the government
really wants to protect people and stop
human smugglers they'll allow uk asylum
claims to be made abroad
crystal commansing global news london
next money tweets why elon musk thinks
twitter is broken and he's the man to
fix it
for a couple of weeks now elon musk has
been taunting twitter buying a stake in
the company agreeing to sit on the board
and then withdrawing from that and then
launching a bid to buy the whole company
it's a 43 billion dollar u.s offer musk
calls himself a free speech absolutist
he says twitter has lost its way and
claims he can unlock its potential
jackson proskow explains what that might
mean
he dominates the electric vehicle
industry endeavor launches and controls
an increasingly large part of outer
space
but it's cyberspace that has grabbed the
attention of elon musk as the world's
richest man looks to indulge his twitter
obsession with a planned hostile
takeover of the social media platform he
seems to be happy to create chaos in
some way or another and and see what the
stock does in response in what he called
his best and final offer musk proposed
to buy twitter at a premium and take the
company private he threatened to sell
his existing 10 percent stake if he
doesn't get his way i'm not sure that i
will actually be able to to acquire it
at the ted 2022 conference in vancouver
musk explained he wants twitter to be
driven by absolute free speech with
almost no rules about what gets posted
it's just really important that people
have the both the uh the reality and the
perception
that they're able to speak freely within
the bounds of the law of course donald
trump wasn't breaking any laws when he
tweeted lies about a stolen election
after his supporters attacked the u.s
capitol twitter banned him for inciting
violence musk seems to be hinting if he
owns the site that could change i really
don't think that that would help with
some of the big issues but twitter is
facing today around you know bullying
and uh
just the um
the toxic environment that sometime is
created on the platform still the 43
billion u.s price tag is a lot even for
a billionaire like musk large
shareholders have already said no thanks
twitter's board would have to approve
the deal i think for the twitter board
and for the executives there this
becomes their worst nightmare even if
musk is unsuccessful his takeover
attempt is likely to force radical
changes at twitter as users debate
whether the big tech platform should
shoulder even bigger responsibilities
jackson proskow global news washington
that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is cape breton island nova
scotia we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching chris gales will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and i will
see you again next week have a lovely
weekend
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you